we have liftoff
space-based observatories provide us
with the unique view of solar activity
in 2006 NASA launched twins
state-of-the-art satellites to study at
close hand solar storms and sunspots
visible signs of deep magnetic activity
that affects the whole solar system
the scientists borrow a trick from 1950s
b-movies to create a 3d image of the Sun
they deployed two satellites orbiting in
tandem one in front of the other so they
can build a three-dimensional image back
on earth this 3d image will provide
crucial new data on massive explosions
of electrified plasma called solar
storms billions of tons of superheated
gas fly into space and Buffett the
Earth's atmosphere creating the most
dramatic northern and southern lights
Michael Kaiser of the Solar terrestrial
relations Observatory or stereo we want
to monitor these storms so that we can
better predict them these storms are
basically electrical storms and they can
affect spacecraft ground power systems
the GPS can be upset solar storms are
caused by lines of magnetic force
ripping through the sun's gaseous
surface and snapping spewing out hot
gases and a fierce stream of charged
particles the most powerful type of
what's called solar wind
some storms take two days to strike the
earth while very large ejections arrive
in only 12 hours stereo could give us
time to put satellites and electric
power grids into safe mode and move
astronauts into protected sections of
the space station the ones we're
interested in the ones coming right at
us are particularly difficult to
estimate the speed and velocity a simple
demo shows how two satellites allow
scientists to calculate the speed of
this solar wind Michael Kaiser ejects a
jet of liquid and a plate of glass from
the front it's difficult to measure the
speed this is the way older satellites
used to view solar storms but from the
side you can measure two points along
the projectile and calculate the speed
more easily studying solar storms not
just from the front but the side as well
doesn't just reveal their speed
it also shows where they come from the
answer turns out to be the area around
sunspots these dark spots on the Sun
surface were shrouded in mystery until
the 20th century when scientists
realized that they were connected with
the way the Sun generates heat at its
core once scientists understood that the
Sun got its energy from nuclear
reactions the answer became clear
nuclear fusion within the Sun creates
the conditions for powerful magnetic
effects the currents of superheated gas
generate intense magnetic fields as the
sun's interior churns vast loops of
magnetic force appear merge and
disappear creating sunspots luckily
there's a way to visualize it right here
on earth in the comfort of your own
kitchen
NASA astronomers Sten Odin wal compares
magnetic field lines to spaghetti the
surface of the Sun is very hot gases
that are turning over in a boiling
motion what you're seeing in the pot of
water is the convecting water coming up
to the surface and releasing its heat
and then sinking back down into the pot
to get reheated the rolling strands of
spaghetti are like the magnetic field
lines churning beneath the sun's surface